and of course on my side
i'm not pessimistic but i'm realistic
and you cannot be realistic when you're
an entrepreneur when you are running a
startup you don't know where your your
money will come from where the next
round when the next round will take
place but still you go on with full
force you don't have a
product yet but still you are trying to
sell it and explain it and
make other people as enthusiastic as you
are and these are really virtues i
admire as entrepreneurs
having said all that i think that the
entrepreneurs should be optimistic maybe
overly optimistic but should bear in
mind all the downside as well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
today i am joined by amir zolte a lawyer
and the head of lipamir's high-tech
practice
over the last 20 years he's been dealing
with high-tech corporate finance privacy
and data security and prior to that he
worked closely with the president of the
supreme court of israel and before that
with the attorney general amir is also
an 8200 alumni and his story is just
fascinating welcome amir
thank you very much for coming and
sharing a little bit about your story
and a little bit about why you do what
you do and today and responsible for the
high-tech and m a sector uh within
lipamirenko and law firm previously
though you've we've also worked in in
the public sector and with toby
university yale and
israeli supreme court and amongst a few
other incredible areas and with the
attorney general as well so
amir walk me through a little bit you
know your sort of legal career what what
has been
sort of the your trajectory that you've
chosen and and how did you end up
working in the tech sector
okay the short answer is by chance
nothing really happened
which was really planned but it's ended
a lot for good
uh
i'll start with my uh military service i
started in the unit a200 and
then i got some exposure to all kinds of
let's call it high tech or early stage
itec of all sorts
and other than that in a200 they give
you the
opportunity to do anything and they give
you the feeling that you can do anything
you can reach anything which is a great
thing when you're
young and
having not too much experience
once i graduated once i
finished my
my military service i
started to learn legal law at tel aviv
university i graduated from tel aviv
university
i was a clerk at the israeli supreme
court and also at a private law firm and
then i went to yale to have my llm
degree
and during my study as a ta i'm sorry
during my study at yale i was amazed to
see that there are so many people who
are hopping between the private sector
and the public sector between being
professors and working in the government
because till then i have i had a very
structured vision of being a lawyer you
go to law school then you become a
private lawyer then you retire after
four years and that's about it nothing
really interesting nothing nothing
really dynamic
and i started asking myself
why get stuck in a private law firm
acting only for private plans and
eventually after i came back to israel
after one year
i had the chance to join the attorney
general's office
which was during the early 90s and it
was a very let's call it a hectic period
in israel with the rabbin administration
with the peace process a lot of protests
and
obviously
eventually the murder of its rocker
being
a after the murder i was appointed as an
investigator the
governmental uh investigating
investigation committee for the measure
of being the champion
which was a
very unique once in a lifetime
experience and
it had nothing to do
with law more than
it was more about fact finding about
interviewing uh witnesses uh people of
the gss and so on and so forth which was
really amazing
incredible in a good night way
what did you learn from that experience
what was that like you know being you
know in trying to figure out what
happened in in one of the most
monumental events of our country's
history
uh okay it's quite complicated i'd say
that
first of all the members of the
committee were impressive
first first and foremost president
chamgar
was a
man of uh i know a hero of his era he's
done so many things he was
so sharp so bright and so devoted to the
task and also the two other members who
are great persons
as for the investigation by itself
first of all we interviewed
all parties involved
beginning with the galamy himself we
went to the jail and me and another
investigator talked with him about two
and a half hours or so about wow the
murder what moved him you by the way you
can find the transcript of such
investigation
and actually it was uh
later on there's a film about the
murderer
a feature film about the murder and
basically took the investigation word by
word and you consider the investigation
verbatim
it was a very moving experience
and it was a very
heartbreaking experience to see both the
shabbat the gss persons
and the police trying to struggle with
the fact that in a way they too were
responsible for such murder they could
have prevented it rather easily and they
failed to do so you know
the gss people had only one job and they
failed and it was very
very sad to see these people
so disappointed of themselves and then
having to encounter all kind of legal
proceedings uh court-like proceedings
so wow this is something
thank you
this is really incredible that i'll
probably remember for the rest of my
life
after that i moved to the supreme court
i worked with president barack the
president of the supreme court for about
four years it was also amazing
very super super bright person
all the most sensitive most complicated
issues were on the table
and then i started asking myself okay
what's next
i reached such heights
such peaks of interest of importers i
didn't feel at that time that there was
something comparable to that in the
public sector and i didn't want to just
stand in line to be a judge within five
ten years and so on
and i really like the short period where
i served as a lawyer at the private
sector
so after uh quite a lengthy shopping i
opened with another partner boutique law
firm
and for some
reason we
focused on high tech
it wasn't my choice it was my partner's
previous career and he was more into it
and i decided to join him
and we've been having a
boutique law firm about 20 years
dealing mostly with high-tech corporate
law and so on
all centered around technology of all
sorts and then we joined liquor mayors
three years ago or so
and they keep doing the same but under a
greater umbrella with amazing partners
of all sorts and now i have much broader
shoulders to rely reliable
incredible not exactly my last story
well i i i i think that we could talk
for hours about about your life story
each of those uh
each of each of these pieces that you me
that he touched on i think can be
expanded so much
if you're looking at the transition from
the public to the private sector you
know going from working with the supreme
court and the attorney general and
working on
on such a sensitive but critical matters
to society transitioning to working in
the tech sector what what is that like
what is that transition like for a
person
uh
okay first of all
there was a there was a lot of stress in
the public sector because all every
almost everything was crucial
and had so much importance and
especially young my
tenure at the attorney general's office
most of it was rather depressing because
things were very challenging and was
really bothered by everything that
happened
once you move to the private sector
it's not life and death it's important
it's crucial it's probably crucial for
the entrepreneurs it's crucial for the
companies who are undergoing ipos or m
a's but it's not the same magnitude
that's on the one hand on the other hand
i felt that i'm doing
many positive things i'm not
against anybody i'm not suing eddie but
i'm not indicting anybody
i'm not acting in court against all kind
of petitions and trying to help build
things
you take entrepreneur hand in hand from
day one you go with him to all rounds of
investments
to
his or her first
commercial transactions and then you get
to the next round then you get to the m
a
and you are not the investor you are not
entrepreneur but still you help them and
you stand by them with them at all
all stages of development of such
issues
and in many cases you feel
fulfilled again it's not life is death
it's not national but still you you meet
a lot of good people you try to hurt
them unless you succeed then it's great
so i didn't feel i don't miss it
i'm very glad i did it i'm very glad i
spent such time at the
public service but i don't think that i
would have
survived till then or
i wouldn't like to spend all my career
in the public sector also in the public
sector
you meet a lot of people who are experts
in their field it may be constitutional
law it may be final law
but they don't really know the real
world because they never conducted any
transaction they never went to court
not represented with the state but the
little person
and the perception is somewhat i would
say lacking
and this is why one of the reasons why i
decided i did i did not want to become a
judge from that position i'd say i need
to know the world i need to speak with
real people and not just be
on the public service thing that i'm
always right and i always
i always do the right thing sometimes i
do the right thing sometimes not and i
rather be
with my two legs on the ground and not
just
sitting in some isolated office
interesting
wha what is your work like with
entrepreneurs if you're looking at
the way that you know you're you're
joining companies early on and then
you're
sort of guiding them
and throughout the way
what is your engagement like and how
involved are you with with you know
their business their idea their
technology whatever they're doing
what is that relationship like okay okay
let's start with technology i think that
one of the most fascinating facets of my
work
is to meet with a new investor a new
entrepreneur and hear
about the new technology the new ideas
the new business trend it's always
amazing because people come up with
such great ideas i'm not an engineer i'm
not i did not write any
one line of software but still i
understand the ideas and they
get some
exp got some experience throughout the
years
my work i believe as the work of many
other high-tech lawyers is very very
close to entrepreneur it's not as if you
see them for one time and that's about
it you go with them for years
and through
throughout all the crisis the ups and
downs and so on so it's very important
at least for me to have a close
relationship with entrepreneurs
let them be very transparent to me
i'd be very frank with them
both
mostly with regard to legal issues but
also with regard to
semi-commercial issues i don't decide
about valuation i don't decide about
who's the right partner but i can share
my experience and say don't aim too high
because later on
you'll be you'll suffer because you
overshoot in this regard
be kind to your investors keep
keep them
abreast at all times because you'll need
them shortly and so on so forth
and as the years passed and then my hair
becomes whiter and whiter i have more
experience to share with entrepreneurs
and i really enjoy the the journey it's
not a one time of course we do also mnas
which takes place i don't know two or
three or four months and that's about it
but the more more exciting is thing uh
euro yo it's not mine but still a
startup grow up
from a toddler to a full-grown startup
with
tens or more than 100 employees and then
international presence and so on and so
forth
so is it more the the legal side of the
of your work or the the sort of the
startup exciting innovative side that
that sort of guides you today
as you
you know as you work as you partner
because you talk a lot about the
partnership you talk a lot about you
know being a part of the journey a part
of the adventure and it you're not
talking as much about the you know the
the legal work which is obviously there
but but what really excites you today
uh first of all the all
there are changes
all all the time the
this whole area develops and you see all
kinds of new agreements safes are rather
new things
cla will become much more prominent
since the beginning of kovit you see new
types of transactions
and in many cases some cases you know
you just have the template and say okay
that's a standard transaction i just
fill in the names and
some details and that's about it that's
not really thrilling
but in many cases i find myself world
crafting you need to address a very
complicated situation and to cover all
scenarios and you have to put it in
writing and sometimes it's not just
writing it's just it's like a
formula about anti-dilution
or down rounds and so on and i really
find myself writing center and saying
hey that's amazing i never wrote this
before
so it's both it's uh both in many cases
the legal work is second to the thrill
of a startup but in some cases you say
okay i'm learning a new subject for the
first time a new legal subject for the
first time i'm working the new
jurisdiction for the first time
it is still amazing after all these
years
i love it if you're looking at the way
that that entrepreneurs today um are
dealing with you know the the legal
areas or or in general you know some
some entrepreneurial behavior you're
seeing them grow from you know sort of
zero to one and then one to one to 100
are there some things that you know
you're particularly inspired by
and and the second piece to that is if
there are things that you observe that
you know new entrepreneurs can look out
for or can think for themselves okay
this is something that i can
that i can improve on when i'll be an
entrepreneur
uh okay
first of all when you first meet with a
team of two or three entrepreneurs you
look at them and say
okay we'll be here in one year or so
because it's so tasking it's so
difficult to be an entrepreneur in a
young startup and you really don't know
who'll
get to the finish line and we'll just
get
exhausted before that and leave and you
think about potential
let's call it disagreements between
entrepreneurs
and
i can see i really admire people who get
up every day more optimistic than the
other days it goes through so many
challenges
it may be geopolitical it's maybe local
it's maybe a
key employee who just decided to leave
because somebody offered them more and
still they they insist they go to work
every day they're
so optimistic and so
sure of themselves
and of course on my side
i'm not pessimistic but i'm realistic
and you cannot be realistic when you're
an entrepreneur when you are running a
starter you don't know where your your
money will come from where the next
round when the next one will take place
but still you go on with full force you
don't have a
product yet but still you are trying to
sell it and explain it and
make other people
as enthusiastic as you are and these are
really virtues that i admire as
entrepreneurs
having said all that i think that the
entrepreneurs should be optimistic maybe
overly optimistic but should bear in
mind all the downside as well and
i try to help them manage the risk and
behave in a manner which will
keep them alive and keep them credible
to their investor to their employees
and to their whole surrounding
environment in order to keep on and
raise another round of money raise more
employees retain employees and so on
is there something about the mentality
that that you think
that that you are particularly
maybe
helpful in in guiding them towards
thinking differently about a process or
or or changing some mentality so that
they have a better grasp on
on on the way that they run their
startups or the way they deal with their
with their legal matters perhaps in
other words from your from your legal
experience and your own angle of things
what do you observe that entrepreneurs
pretty you know across the board can
benefit
from sort of your background and the way
that you see the world
i think that i can try and help them
with regards to priorities and risk
taking and risk management
if you i don't know a startup which
deals with
personal data
and you need to comply with so many
legal requirements all over the globe
you don't have the resources you don't
have the people you don't have the funds
but you should at least start to be
aware of it start to plan where you'll
do that and when you'll do that you need
to know how to spend your money at phase
one then it's phase two and then it's
phase three so i'm trying to tell them
what's important and what's not and uh
what's important as of when something
okay you probably should have done this
but nobody can really expect you to do
this at this stage but once you get the
first massive investment you must do
this and this because otherwise nobody
will talk to the
big boys or email and
trying to
make some order because many
entrepreneurs are very uh
product oriented development oriented
which is fine but it's not enough
so i'm trying right help them get to
know other aspects as well
i love it and amira i really appreciate
your time not just your insights in the
way that you are
it's very clear and evident that you're
you know your passion lies in in working
with the entrepreneurs today and guiding
them through that zero to one and then
one to 100 phase you're not just
taking the legal work you're you're
you're part of the journey and you're
you get you get personally inspired and
excited by
the the resilience and the optimism and
that clearly comes across but but even
more inspiring than that it is you know
your background with the supreme court
and the attorney general i'm dealing
with some of the most uh fascinating uh
tragic and uh
and crazy things that have happened in
this country
and even before that with yale
and tau so again thank you very much for
for being here and sharing these 20
minutes with me and not nearly enough to
encompass your journey but i loved it
thank you very very much thank you
enjoyed it
thank you
you